[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh sorry son born aside Nisa
[Applause]
[Music]
rejoice
Hey
[Music]
baby for evidence of day the Sun is
risen
where no son is
[Music]
let and hide prepare to see any truly to
see
[Music]
to see what none may see no singer
singer
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen may I please have
your attention the academic procession
led by the chief marshal will now enter
Killian Court the audience will please
be seated
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the guest of honor
the class of 1985
[Applause]
[Music]
the corporation and the faculty of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology an
hour are now declared convened together
with this assembly on the occasion of
the graduation exercises of this
institution for the conferring of its
degrees the stage assembly and audience
will please rise for the singing of one
verse of the national anthem and then be
seated
while Robert rabbi Shabbats offers the
invocation
[Music]
the conventional role of one who
delivers the invocation at such
occasions is to ask the Almighty for his
blessing on your Labor's but I must
issue this assignment God's blessing
though indispensable is not sufficient
our tradition teaches that the Holy One
blessed be he has delivered the power of
blessing to his children who share the
responsibility for maintaining his
creation and now it is you you who have
labored so hard these many years who
have mastered your various disciplines
and learned the ways of excellence it is
you who are the source of blessing and
curse in the world scripture teaches us
this day I have set before you life and
death blessing and curse choose life so
that you and your offspring may live
this choice has offered us not once it
will present itself every day of your
professional careers the knowledge you
have acquired here will help you make
this choice hopefully you will choose
life and spread blessings throughout
your communities and among your
neighbors so it is to you that I address
this invocation let your Labor's be for
blessings and not for curses as you pass
this milestone you go out into new
worlds to spread blessings some to
industry some to academia
some to governmental service and some to
that darkest recess where blessings are
so far hard to find it all graduate
school but all of you I am certain will
be in a position to make decisions that
will have unfathomable repercussions
throughout our society and perhaps the
world and I would like to offer my hopes
for how you will avoid sowing curses and
destruction but rather to affirm life
and blessing
first of all train your tongues to say I
don't know much of the evil that the
sets us is due to people who are too
ashamed of their ignorance to be silent
humility is the true parent of wisdom
don't assume that you are indispensable
to your project such haughtiness even if
warranted is ultimately misguided leave
room for others even if you are right
others may have a different piece of the
truth make time for your families the
ethic that puts achievement ahead of
loving relationships is a wicked one
your children will need loving fathers
and mothers your spouse's loving
husbands and wives and your comrades a
good friend more than society needs your
12-hour days be home in time for dinner
many of you will be employers or
supervisors that is an awesome
responsibility remember that those who
work for you are created in God's image
just as you are your MIT credentials do
not give you license to mistreat them
give them the space and time they need
to be human efficiency is an important
goal but to elevate it to the Suman
bonum is idolatry efficiency must give
way to justice rectitude and compassion
if our society is to prosper
relationships are fragile they bruise
easily treat them with respect a harsh
word our retreat from honor or a tawdry
compromise can propagate throughout
society and unlike automobiles they
cannot be recalled one more lesson from
our tradition the Bible tells us of
Moses encounter with Pharaoh and that he
brought a plague of frogs on the land to
Humble the wicked oppressors Pharaoh we
are told summoned his magicians and
asked for advice these magicians and
they might well have been the engineers
of those days responded well that's not
a difficult problem we too can make
frogs and so they did
seeing their assignment as a
professional problem to be solved using
the tools of their discipline they
achieved a technical breakthrough
without ever realizing that the very
last thing they needed was more frogs
now it may not fall to your lot to
redeem a whole world steeped in slavery
and oppression but at the very least
you can promise yourself that you will
make no more frogs make IOL Kyle may you
go from valor to ever greater valor and
may the vision of God always be the for
you
Thank You rabbi Shepherds I am pleased
to welcome to this platform mr. Lee a
Iacocca chairman of the board of
directors and chief executive officer of
the Chrysler Corporation mr. Iacocca
will now give the commencement address
thank you dr. Saxon a good morning
you only been here about an hour and
I've all had a little little bit of
pressure put on me no less than six
trustees have reminded me that Winston
Churchill spoke to the commencement
class 36 years ago they said it was the
biggest crowd that they ever had at a
commencement that he gave his usual
rousing speech but most important the
audience was upbeat and enthusiastic you
have to remember now that he had one
huge advantage over me the Celtics were
not down to 2-1 in the championship
series that year but if you'll just hang
in there trust me they're gonna win it
in seven the hard way
but president gray members of the MIT
corporation members of the faculty
distinguished guests and parents and
members of the class of 1985 thank you
for asking me to share this very special
day with all of you and it is a special
day it's a day for all of you graduates
to thank your teachers for their hard
work and your parents for all their
sacrifices and by the way don't forget
to Pat yourselves on the back too you
deserve it and my hat is off to every
one of you I asked one of your alumni at
Chrysler to tell me a little bit about
MIT students he said quickly they're all
brilliant but they're too intense and
they're too competitive he said the only
thing they can't seem to learn is how to
relax well let me tell you relax today
it's your day enjoy it
relax but don't go to sleep because
tomorrow the real final exams start then
they'll go on for the rest of your lives
I'm going to try to give you a little
peek at the test but I won't be able to
help you with the answers they'll have
to come from you but in case you'll want
to take a nap for the next 20 minutes or
so I'll give you the ending to this
speech right now I'm going to tell you
to go out and change the world that's my
duty right that's what every
commencement speaker says and every
graduating class just sits there hoping
he'll be brief so they cannot go uncork
the champagne but musing to themselves
if the world had to be changed why in
the hell did he do it
well my generation tried pretty hard at
times and with some success I might add
i sat in your place in those happy days
at the end of World War two that was a
good war you know the one in all those
old Ronald Reagan movies our future
couldn't have been brighter then America
was flushed with victory we were king of
the hill the undisputed leaders in the
whole world
Russia soon got some funny ideas about
that however but believe it or not back
in those innocent days
a lot of people really thought we had a
chance to build a perfect world I wasn't
too sure
I graduated from Lehigh but I kept my
mouth shut because I didn't want to
spoil it for the rest of them well a few
things went wrong there were a couple
more Wars there were eight recessions
there was Watergate and a dozen other
man-made disasters along the way but in
spite of all that we did manage to wipe
out a few diseases we put a man on the
moon and we produced more technological
change than all of those who came before
us and I mean combined and we made
America I think a little more just a
little more fair and maybe a little bit
more humane all in all we really haven't
done a bad job and if you believe
everything you read in the papers the
country must be in terrific shape
the stock market just went over 1,300
companies are spending billions of
dollars just buying each other up and
the public is on a buying binge too
they're buying lots of expensive cars
and houses say things are so good even
Chrysler made 2.4 billion dollars last
year and we were broke five years ago
and you and you how about you well
you've got the world by the tail you're
all going to make a bundle of money next
year at least some of you will be uppies
sooner than you think
we call anybody a yuppie who's around 40
and makes 40 grand a year hell we're
hiring some 20 years 20 year olds at
almost $40,000 thirty three thousand to
start by the way for engineers to be
exact I guess you'd call them baby
yuppies or Guppies or I say yuppies
twenty years ahead of their time but to
be honest with you we're handing you
more than anybody has ever passed on to
their kids generations ahead of you were
lucky if they inherited a little shack
on the back forty you're getting a big
beautiful mansion on a hill that's what
we're leaving you now before you get all
choked up with gratitude I should tell
you one more thing we haven't paid for
this yet we're leaving you the mansion
all right but it's got a little mortgage
on it about 1.7 trillion dollars in fact
going to two trillion whatever that is
in just a couple of years that's a
public debt we're gonna hand this class
and if you don't like the deal if you
don't want the mansion I'm sorry because
it's yours along with the note you can't
give it back but you can't get mad about
it
in fact I hope you do I'm mad too I
think the mortgage you're picking up is
a national scandal right now we're
paying a hundred and fifty billion
dollars a year in interest alone on our
national debt and adding almost two
hundred billion a year on the principle
for a long time we fought a battle with
inflation in this country we beat it but
we paid a heavy price we paid a price in
unemployment in high interest rates and
in bigger federal deficits and we did
weak in many of our basic industries
especially housing and autos now
inflation is bad enough it's an economic
evil let's hope it stays in its own
little hole but at least inflation is a
penalty we pay now it takes money out of
your pockets every day it's sort of a
pay-as-you-go penalty but these huge
deficits are a penalty penalty that we
keep deferring we're going to leave them
for you it's not pay-as-you-go anymore
it's more like passes of plastic it's a
credit card approach and it's your
credit card we're using what makes this
debt so insidious is that so much of it
is invisible I often say that the
government ought to be forced to follow
the truth-in-lending law every year at
tax time it should have to send out a
statement to you just like your bank
does and that statement would tell every
American family where he or she stands
this year for the average family it
would go something like this dear mr.
and mrs. taxpayer this year your
family's share of the national debt
stands at twenty-seven thousand nine
hundred and fifty dollars in the past
twelve months your share is increased by
thirty nine hundred and eighty dollars
your share of the interest bill this
year
is twenty one hundred and twenty seven
dollars have a nice day now maybe a
notice that one line is missing from
that statement the one that says please
remit we aren't remitting we aren't
paying our own way because there are no
free lunches in this life that bill has
to be paid some day and I guess you get
the honor and unless by the way you want
to float it long enough to give it to
your kids but I sure hope you don't I
understand you have something here at
MIT called hacking well somebody is
pulling a hack on your future piling up
debt to create the illusion of
prosperity as a cruel hoax and the joke
my young friends is on you now let me
pause you let me ask you how am i doing
so far is anybody mad yet well if you're
not thank you one guy here if you're not
let me go one step further let me tell
you about our second national scandal
one that will put another dark cloud
over your futures I'm talking about a
trade deficit that's going right off the
charts our trade deficit in goods last
year was 123 billion dollars that's 1980
just 48 months ago we had a 40 billion
dollar surplus so we had a negative
swing of 163 billion bucks in less than
four years and we're on a toboggan ride
right now we will probably go 150
billion dollars in the hole this year
alone these two scandals of course are
related by the way the trade imbalance
is a bastard child of those huge
deficits that raise interest rates and
throw the dollar out of whack the high
dollar makes American goods cost more
and give foreign products a big leg up
American companies I'm part of one can
work night and day to get more
productive three years ago we built 10
cars per employee at Chrysler per year
now we build 20 cars per employee per
year but the currency problem just
throws all that effort right out the
window
that's one side of the problem our own
fiscal irresponsibility creates at high
dollar and we can't blame anybody else
for it we have to fix that ourselves
but there's another side of the problem
even when we are competitive we're
facing a crazy festival of trade
barriers all over the place that keeps
our products out of other countries
consider Japan last year the Japanese
sold us 37 billion dollars worth of
products more than we sold em that's a
37 billion dollar deficit with just one
country in one year if you disregard oil
imports 62 percent of our total grade
deficit worldwide comes from trade with
Japan alone now the high dollar accounts
for a lot of that but so does the fact
that Japan protects its whole markets it
does so rather openly and without much
apology Japan is a free and sovereign
nation and it has a right to act in its
own self-interest but guess what so do
we we've got a right to go to the
Japanese as close friends and trading
partners and say look we got us 37
billion dollar problem here we can't
handle that it has to come down if for
internal political reasons you can't buy
American rice or oranges even though
they're much cheaper than your own
that's ok with us but then you'll have
to cut back on some of the heavy traffic
coming the other way across the Pacific
you see that imbalance isn't just an
American problem
it's Japan's problem too it's a mutual
problem because if it isn't solved soon
your Congress will be forced to take
drastic action the Senate God'll of them
has already fired a shot across their
bow by voting 92 to nothing to retaliate
because of Japan's closed markets now
that's pretty significant when you
consider the Congress can't even get a
unanimous vote to go home for Christmas
so we'll probably see a lot of
finger-pointing for a while and that
could hurt everybody
now consenting adults just show an act
like that we should sit down and reason
this out no threats no talk a trade war
just an absolutely firm understanding
that America has something to protect to
and that we intend to protect it we
intend to protect our ability to compete
but we aren't doing that last March we
took all import restrictions off of
Japanese
we said to them look how generous we are
now what are you going to do for us and
the Japanese said thank you very much
we're going to send 24% more cars in
this year than we did last year we got
nothing in return
we got some promises but we get a list
of promises every year our guys who go
over to negotiate are supposed to bring
home the bacon for America once in a
while now I don't blame the Japanese for
a minute they are very good businessmen
they are managing their trade according
to the unwritten rules used by almost
every other country in the world and
those rules are simple devised trade
policies that help your own companies
compete we in the other hand are
worshipping at the altar of free trade
we're blindly wedded to a set of lofty
principles that everybody else in the
world ignores we've got this silly
notion that it's a mortal sin to play by
the rules everybody else is using were
the ones who're out of step today not
the Japanese they're in step with the
rest of the world we're not I always say
we're like those few crazy hockey
players who still refuse to wear their
helmets and we're getting our brains
beat out now don't get me wrong I
believe in free trade who doesn't I
think it's a beautiful ideal it's right
up there with goodness and mercy and
charity for all but it is not one of the
Ten Commandments it's not the way the
world works and we aren't going to
change that all by ourselves
maybe someday we'll achieve that ideal I
really hope so but I'm not willing to
risk your futures waiting for that
blessed occasion you see one impact of
these twin scandals may be the
deindustrialization of America in fact
the process is really well underway go
to Pittsburgh or to Akron or Detroit
you'll see it all around you American
heavy industry all smokestack America is
slowly dying many of the companies that
helped build the industrial middle class
the backbone of the country in this
century are boarded up why they can't
compete anymore they can't compete
because our currency and trade policies
have tilted the international playing
field against them and they're getting
short of breath from running uphill
maybe they could use a
we're either we got one at Chrysler six
years ago with the federal loan
guarantees and it saved us I've
suggested some kind if you'll perish
ignore the term Industrial Policy I've
suggested some kind of policy to help
other companies in trouble but the
purists say it would wreck free
enterprise forever I don't know why
Chrysler is a bastion of free enterprise
today we're making lots and lots of
money we're paying lots of taxes quarter
billion in 90 days that ain't bad for
guys who were broke six hundred thousand
people have jobs who would have been on
the street the government never put up a
cent and not only got its 1.2 billion of
guarantees back seven years early but it
made three hundred and fifty million
dollars on the deal - boo pure profit
the Chrysler loan guarantee board wasn't
a welfare office it was a profit Center
they don't have any idea what that means
done in Washington by the way let me be
blunt until we fix the currency problem
and write a trade policy and an
industrial policy for America to compete
it's going to make less and less sense
for companies to build plants and put
people to work in America our trade
deficit has already caused to 3 million
jobs and more going overseas every day
the economics when you think of it are
pretty simple you build it in the end
and you sell it in dollars and you don't
need a degree from MIT to figure that
out
hell they probably understand that even
over at Harvard well maybe some of you
right about this point maybe some of you
feel that maybe we should
deindustrialization put everybody to
work in service industries or hey maybe
even better high-tech I have to admit
that the weather's nicer in Silicon
Valley than it is in Detroit but let me
tell you if America gives up its
industrial base there is no future for
high-tech either because we smokestack
guys are your best customers for all the
wizardry that comes from Silicon Valley
or from up here on route 28
we put high tech to work we put it to
work in our plants we've got robots and
lazer cameras
all over the joint now we've got some of
the world's finest CAD cam facilities of
course we put it to work every day in
our cars to our new laser in Daytona
sports cars have seven this is
commercial as I get today I have have
seven mini micro processors or many
computers in each car and unless you put
it to work unless you use it to compete
high tech is really just a toy how much
do you think a bag of silicon chips
would bring in a supermarket anyway your
future depends on an America that can
hook and jab in the international
marketplace never forget that and right
now we're falling behind and fast right
now America is getting whipped right now
our three largest exports to Japan
you've heard this before our corn this
order soybeans coal Japan's largest
exports dosser cars trucks video
recorders raw materials and foodstuffs
traded for manufactured goods does the
pattern sound a little familiar
it's the classic definition of a colony
that's what deindustrialization and
weak-kneed trade policies are doing to
America they're making us a colony again
we were a colony once before but we got
so mad we threw the tea into the harbor
and not very far from where I'm standing
by the way well here we are becoming a
colony again and I mean that and I hope
it really makes you mad so get mad don't
burn the place down or start dumping
things into the river here but get mad
get mad because some people are saying
that you're going to be the first
generation of Americans who will have to
settle for less than their parents had I
hope that God you aren't listening to
them I hope you don't believe that
because it does not have to be true it
doesn't have to be true because even
though we've taken our eye off the ball
this is still America and your
birthright as Americans is to change
things in America when people get mad
enough they can change anything
righteous anger intelligently directed
has made this the greatest democracy in
the world I hope every cancer researcher
in the country goes to work every
morning
mad and every engineer and economist
even and teacher and congressman
satisfied people changed nothing only
angry people changed things I got mad
six years ago really mad when the Wall
Street Journal said a little prayer over
Chrysler in one of their editorials and
told us in big bold type please die with
dignity a lot of people that Chrysler
got mad as hell at that kind of advice
they got so mad they scratched and they
clawed and they survived so you get mad
to get mad at the people in Washington
who are burying you under a dung heap of
public debt tell them
no more get mad at the free lunches of
the world and tell them no more it's
time for sacrifice get mad at the
ideologues who want to make you martyrs
to some eighteenth century trade
principals who want you to live in a
colony tell them no more we want to
compete and get mad at anybody who tells
you that you have to settle for Less
tell them get the hell out of my way you
owe that to yourselves your education is
as good as anybody can get anywhere
remember that you're smart enough to
compete with anybody in the world and
you deserve the chance to be the best
you owe it to yourselves and to those
who follow you too now you're not
getting a perfect world but I hope you
all appreciate what has been given to
you I hope you feel a deep appreciation
for what other people have done so that
you could be here today but I also hope
you understand how you pay that debt it
doesn't get paid to me or my generation
or to your teachers or even to your
parents you know there's a scene in the
movie a guess who's coming to dinner
a father is very angry with his son and
he says I carried that mailbag for 40
years so you could go to college into
Medical School you owe me for that and
the son says hey I owe you nothing if
you carried that mailbag a million miles
you did what you were supposed to do you
owed me everything you could ever do for
me just as I
all my kids the Sun wasn't ungrateful he
loved and respected his father but he
also understood our civilization is
supposed to work one generation making
things a little better for the next
fathers and mothers sacrificing
everything for their kids that's how we
got where we are today that's the way
civilization is supposed to work now my
generation is leaving you with too much
debt we're little blind to some of the
new economic realities in the world
we're leaving here with a lot of
problems to solve big deal but that's
the way civilization works to every
generation inherits the unfulfilled
dreams of the one that came before it
and every generation inherits its own
set of challenges we were naive 40 years
ago thinking we had a shot at making a
perfect world but in many ways we made
it a lot better for you
and by the way we're not through yet
almost but not yet you more than most
have been given the tools to meet your
own set of challenges a degree from MIT
just about guarantees you at least a
shot at molding the future it's a
prestigious ticket and it puts you right
up in front of the pack but let me tell
you it may also be a bit of a burden to
you people are gonna expect more of you
they're expecting you to be leaders and
to be winners your MIT degree puts you
in the pole position as they say and the
green flag is about to go up so now
let's see if you're mad enough to make
this imperfect world just a little
better for your kids let's see what
you're made of so class of 85 start your
engines
mr. Iacocca we pride ourselves at MIT on
our ability to challenge our students to
make them see things in a different way
and think about things a little bit
differently the highest praise I can
give you your speech is to say that it
lived fully up to MIT standards thank
you very much
and now ladies and gentlemen the John
Oliver chorale and the Boston brass
ensemble conducted by John Corley will
provide a musical interlude
[Music]
a children's room is great for my
wondrous works and ways
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
and now Miss Inga gate Oh permanent
president of the senior class will
present the class gift to president gray
following this president gay gray will
present the charge to the graduates
thank you dr. Saxon and good morning to
you all it'll be a little difficult to
follow the address of such a keynote
speaker as mr. Iacocca but I'll give it
my best shot
within the next hour we will turn our
brass rats around move our tassels from
one side to the other and march across
this stage to receive our diplomas from
dr. gray all signifying what we've known
for at least three days now and probably
long for four years our graduation
departure from this Institute of higher
learning commencement however is also a
beginning we will be alumni of the
foremost Technical University in the
world and someday we will be the
Einsteins grays and Iacocca's of this
world and leaving this phase of our
lives we can recall the memories of
these last four years we started our MIT
adventure in this very same Court and
since then have experienced probably the
best and worst times we might ever have
all of which have contributed to the
growth of each of us as individuals in
the society the education we've received
has been the focus of our lives here
never have so many worked so hard for so
much in our pursuit of excellence we
have strived for the success we have
achieved but academics is only a part of
our unique MIT experience mit has placed
great demands and responsibilities upon
us and as we have learned to work hard
we've learned to play hard also much of
the confidence and pride in ourselves
that we take with us and show the world
comes from those times when we were not
studying those precious hours were spent
in activities and sports too numerous to
list talking with friends or just
relaxing I think it's been the people
here who have been most important to
each other the inspiration that kept us
coming back for more
our friends and special people in our
lives and yes our parents and families
whose support was invaluable have made
these for years what they were the many
exceptional rather than merely adequate
opportunities and almost unlimited
possibilities available all qualities
which make MIT the unique place it is
are due in large part to the generosity
of those who came before us so in
keeping with tradition and giving
recognition to the part of our learning
that developed developed us into the
human beings that we are the graduating
class leaves a gift in our name to the
MIT community in hopes of enhancing the
lives of the remaining students as well
as those to come president Grey will you
join me in appreciation of all that we
have received from MIT and the impact
that the people and environment have
made on our lives we the members of the
class of 1985 wish to present to you our
senior gift of three thousand six seven
hundred and sixteen dollars helped by a
generous matching gift from the 50th
reunion class of 1935 this figure now
totals nine thousand one hundred and
twenty seven dollars this fund will be
used to develop with landscaping seating
and appropriate trees the corner of
Danforth street and Amherst alley into a
class of 1985 common to be a welcoming
oasis for MIT students and the community
members a pleasant outdoor spot to read
study or contemplate we give this gift
in good faith and trust that if in
future years it need be removed the
administration will replace it in like
fashion to the satisfaction of the class
I'm also pleased to announce that the
class of 1985 has pledged eighteen
thousand five hundred and thirty five
dollars to the Alumni fund to be
contributed over the next four years
much of it designated for scholarship
money in addition the class of 1985 in
conjunction with the athletic department
has established the Jimmy Lester award
named after a former member of the
athletic training staff to be given
annually to a person who has contributed
exceptionally to one aspect of
athletics at MIT dr. gray these gifts
and pledges are our way of saying thank
you thank you very much thank you thank
you very much Inga dr. Saxon Coco ladies
and gentlemen may I begin with the
observation that I'm the man in the
middle I come after that the addresses
by the head of Chrysler and the head of
your class and just before the ultimate
awarding of your degrees which is why
you and your families came this morning
in short I know my place and my remarks
therefore will be brief first I want to
say to each of you congratulations you
have completed the most rigorous and
demanding collegiate course of
instruction in the nation in so doing
you enter that legendary band of
survivors who are proud to count
themselves graduates of this great
University
now you've not reached this moment by
yourselves I like to think that the gift
of an MIT education is priceless but you
know and your families know that it was
not a gift and that it certainly had a
price it is to the families that I wish
first to call attention and I call
therefore upon all the graduates to join
me in an expression of gratitude to the
great company of family and friends who
through sacrifice and love have made
this day possible
well the graduates please stand face
those wonderful people in the audience
and give them the applause and the
thanks they so richly deserve
I began these remarks by observing that
I am the man in the middle that's a
familiar feeling for most college
presidents and one I have experienced
often during the past five years it
might be more accurate however to
observe that the university is the
institution in the middle in the middle
of the continuing experiment we know as
democracy for both the University and
for Democratic Society the common
hallmarks are the free and open
expression of ideas the embrace of
pluralistic beliefs the reliance on
civil discourse all in the development
of common cause just as the university
takes its primary direction and
priorities from the faculty so a
Democratic Society draws its strength
and its mandate from consultation and
consensus among its citizens I would
like to speak briefly this morning about
the university's role in debates on
matters of public interest at the
university the principles of open
expression and academic freedom has
faced challenges over the years from
within and without
we have weathered those challenges and
have stood firm against efforts to place
limits on inquiry and on open discourse
among members of the academic community
as many of you know in the past few
years we've witnessed some efforts by
the federal government to restrict
information about university based
research on the grounds that without
such restrictions sensitive technologies
may be transferred unintentionally to
potential adversaries these efforts have
been much muted in the past year largely
because the Univ
community has been successful in
persuading policymakers in the
government that science is an enterprise
which depends for its vitality and for
its strength on free open and widely
shared communication and access and the
nation depends on the vitality of
science and engineering for continued
prosperity innovation and economic
growth we should not assume however that
concerns regarding the independence of
the universities can be put behind us
more recently two different issues have
highlighted the dilemma of the
university in the middle first the
funding of science research under
President Reagan's Strategic Defense
Initiative the program known popularly
as Star Wars has created controversy
within the scientific and academic
communities we have recently learned
that the SDI program will fund basic
research and universities and that the
funding of some ongoing research
programs which are relevant to SDI
may be shifted to that program the head
of the SDI's office of innovative
science and technology has asserted that
the participation of university
researchers in SDI funded projects will
add prestige and credibility and will
influence the congress to be more
generous and funding for the program the
impact of this manipulative effort to
garner implicit institutional
endorsement for SDI comes with special
force because of the controversial
nature and the unresolved public policy
aspects of SDI second there has been a
renewal of efforts at colleges and
universities around the country MIT
included to persuade these institutions
to take an active stance against the
government of South Africa and its
system of apartheid
these efforts have primarily taken the
form of calls for the universities to
sell their stock and US corporations
which do business in South Africa I
share the view that apart Aid is an evil
unsupportable and vicious system I would
like to see it end the sooner the better
even those of us who decry that system
however hold differing views as to the
consequences of divestment for the
majority of people in that country for
its government for the corporations
involved and for the universities who
hold stock in those companies there is
no agreement on the best course of
action and there is a major question
again of how far a university chartered
for academic purposes and educational
functions should go in the direction of
using the resources entrusted to it for
the purpose of influencing social policy
in each of these two cases efforts are
made to nudge the university out of the
middle to put it in the position in
which its influence and authority or
prestige are used to achieve goals which
are only remotely related to the
academic purpose or to the vital
internal interests of the university now
obviously there are situations in which
it's appropriate for a university for
this university to speak with an
institutional voice on political issues
our steadfast opposition to constraints
on access to research and on free
communication of results as in the case
of technology transfer is one such
example
the test if you will is whether the
issue at hand has a clear ambiguous
unambiguous and direct connection to the
essential activities of the institution
every time a university moves beyond
this boundary it invites political
treatment of its own interests and it
disenfranchises those within the
institution whose views are different
great caution is required in such
matters
this is not to say that the academic
community should not participate in the
debate on matters of public interest
questions regarding the establishment of
national priorities policies and
allocation of resources must be informed
by the will and judgment of the people
reflected and expressed within the
Congress the national debate on these
issues can and should be invigorated and
illuminated by discussion and reflection
within the universities beyond that
universities have a responsibility to
communicate these insights to the public
and to policymakers alike what I find
particularly troublesome about the SDI
funding is the effort to short-circuit
this debate and to use MIT and other
universities as political instruments in
an attempt to obtain implicit
institutional endorsement this
university will not be so used any
participation at MIT and SDI funded
research will in no way be understood or
used as an institutional endorsement of
the SDI program I have begun the process
of communicating this view to
appropriate persons in the government
and I will continue to do so with
reference to divestment it is the policy
of the Institute to urge companies in
which it invests and which do business
in South Africa to comport themselves in
ways which improve the status and
condition of their South African
employees I believe that this policy is
appropriate both in terms of its effect
on that nation and in terms of the
Institute's mission and responsibilities
and I supported in conclusion I suggest
once again that our continued
effectiveness as an educational
institution as a focal point for
research and scholarship and as a place
in which the views of all members of the
community are afforded the proper
respect and credibility depends on our
careful adherence to the principle that
within very broad limits
we should endeavor to be neutral as an
institution in all matters which do not
have a direct and immediate effect on
this place I'm convinced that holding
fast to the principles of open
expression academic freedom and
institutional neutrality both serves the
national interest and manifests our
institutional purposes our greatest
strength is a commitment to the
unfettered exploration and discussion of
ideas
similarly the free and open expression
of ideas the embrace of pluralistic
beliefs and the reliance on civil
discourse to reach our goals are at the
heart of the democratic society in which
we live as you leave these halls
I urge you to carry these traditions
with you and bring your voices and your
talents to bear on the questions which
will determine the future directions of
this society and of this planet goodbye
make good sense and good fortune go with
you
Thank You president gray by virtue of
the authority delegated to him by the
corporation of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology and on the
recommendation of the faculty president
gray will now present the degrees of
Bachelor of Science Master of
Architecture master and City Planning
master of science advanced engineer
Doctor of Science and Doctor of
Philosophy Dean Perkins Dean of the
Graduate School and professor Smith
chairman of the faculty will invest the
hoods the name of each graduate will be
read by the Dean of the school the first
persons to be recognized are the class
marshals who are seated on this stage
I'm pleased to recognize the marshals of
the class of 1985 and the president of
the graduate student council miss Inga
Godot permanent president of the class
of 1985 is receiving the degree of
Bachelor of Science and humanities and
science
Michael Richard candan president of the
class of 1985 is entering the final year
of a five-year program leading to the
simultaneous award of Bachelor of
Science and computer science and
engineering and Bachelor of Science has
recommended by the Department of Biology
Robyn Luanne Barker executive committee
member of the class of 1985 is receiving
the degree of Bachelor of Science and
electrical engineering
[Applause]
renning Joseph McClair jr. president of
the Graduate Student Council
to all of the fine young men men and
women who have received their degrees
today I now say congratulations I wish
you well in your future endeavors
the 119 graduation exercises of the
massachusetts institute of technology
are now concluded following these
exercises the president will hold a
reception in the adjacent lower dupont
and lower courts for graduates and their
guests graduates are requested to four
gather there in the area designated for
their school the audience is requested
to remain seated until the completion of
the academic procession the stage
assembly and graduates will now please
rise thank you
[Music]
you